someone came up to me the other day and
they were like sauce is his cheap agent
it's just so much why I was like you
have no idea because Sansa she's been
putting on this facade of her former
self she's been pretending to be
innocent and naive for the past maybe
season and people don't realize that
she's picking up all the handy headaches
from Cersei and Margaery and she's
eventually gonna use them again during
whether they like it or not well maybe
not my treatment issues at all but you
know people like his Cersei and Joffrey
and you know Tywin they all go to watch
the backs
Sansa's coming together big time she's
definitely growing into herself she's
not this season she kind of becomes the
real sorcerer as people would definitely
like to see her instead of you know
being so disillusioned by fairytales and
princesses she definitely she becomes
kind of this woman who really realizes
that the world is not a fairytale life
is not a fairy tale but she's probably
the most pessimistic character on the
show from now on because she knows
everything and she knows that she can't
trust anyone I mean look how much she's
not from little finger she she is so
wise now she'd be a very good Queen but
I do think she wants to become queen if
it means marrying Joffrey so for now I
want let's leave her off the throne but
maybe in maybe maybe in the future maybe
one day she'll become queen that would
be
you